la chronique de l'environnement on va
voir ce soir si votre logement est bien
isolé c'est important puisque le temps
s'est refroidi Valérie donc il va
falloir justement veiller à ce que tout
soit bien qu'el feut tré les fenêtres
tout on va parler des mesures
thermographiqu notamment oui elles ont
été effectuées à 50 an en Eveline sur
cette commune le 8 mars
2012 pour en parler ce soir Véronique le
sang du Laboratoire national de
métrologie et d'essas et Johann Girbau
de l'Agence Locale de l'énergie et du
climat bonsoir et merci à tous les deux
d'être sur notre plateau donc je
m'adresse tout d'abord à vous Véronique
Leon puisque c'est le LNE qui a
effectuer ces mesures thermographique
alors comment on capte ces ces mesures
comment on procède donc pour capter ces
mesure nous utilisons un avion dans
lequel est intégré un capteur
radiométrique un
scanner pour en fait cet avion est un
avion bimoteur c'est pour pouvoir
respecter les contraintes aéronautiques
qui nous sont imposées puisque ce sont
des survols que l'on fait au-dessus de
zon urbaines la nu avion qui a survolé
cette partie du département donc de 51
en ieline pour pour vérifier l'isolation
on voit quelques images là où c'est
indiqué en rouge c'est qu'il faut
s'inquiéter c'est ça non c'est en bleu
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de bleu là pas
forcément on parlerit plus tard sur
l'analyse justement et l'interprétation
de ces images puisque il y a beaucoup de
facteurs qui qui rentrent en compte pour
pouvoir interpréter correctement ces
images alors quelles sont les conditions
car elles doivent être particulières qui
doivent être réunies pour effectuer ces
mesures thermographiques donc pour
assurer des mesures de qualité nous
devons effectivement respecter des
conditions météorologiques à savoir un
temps froid de façon à ce qu'il y ait un
bon contraste entre l'extérieur et
l'intérieur s'assurer que les
habitations soient chauffées un temps
sec pas de pluie pas de neige de façon à
ce que les toitures soient sèches qu'il
n'y ait pas de givrage et que nous
modifions pas les propriités radiatives
des toitures un vent faible quasi nul de
façon à diminuer les déperditions par
convection oui effectivement et pour et
pour également assurer la sécurité de
l'avion donc c'est pas des des choses
qui peuvent se c'est pas une date qui
peuvent se décider longtemps à l'avance
he non non non nous devons faire une
veille météo quotidienne pour pouvoir
attendre le jour J pour effectuer ces
mesures et se dire voilà c'est ce soir
on y va c'est ce soir on y va mais en
fait on fait une veille météo à la
semaine et nous avons quand même des
prévisions qui nous permettent
d'envisager un jour dans la semaine et
nous confirmons cette veille par par une
veille la veille et le jour J avec une
veille également sur les conditions
aéronautiques d'accord alors ensuite le
LNE a transmis ses ses données à la
communauté d'aglo qui les avait commandé
c'est ça et à l'Agence Locale de
l'énergie et du climat nous nous les
avons livrés à la collectivité à
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin puisque
notre don c'est l'agglomération de
saquentin d'accord et l'analyse le
résultat parce que derrière tout ça on
peut savoir est-ce que sur 5qutin on
justement ça se passe Johan Girbau
puisque vous vous êtes chargé mission
énergie et climat au sein de l'ALEC
comment on peut interpréter ces ces
données alors tout d'abord ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que la termographie
aérienne de 50 ans iveline elle a été
réalisée en effet à la demande de la
communauté d'agglomération de CS en
Yveline et la communauté d'agglomération
de saant en Yveline s'appuie sur donc
l'ALC pour pouvoir transmettre les
résultats pour pouvoir analyser les
résultats avec les habitants de la
Communauté d'Agglomération pour cela les
habitants de la Communauté
d'Agglomération sont invités à venir
prendre conseil auprès de nos services
donc am Manil les amau ou par téléphone
ils peuvent prendre un rendez-vous voilà
on peut pas avoir ces données sur
Internet il faut impérativement venir
vous voir non puisqueen réalité euh
l'analyse thmographique est beaucoup
plus complexe que uniquement dire si
c'est rouge c'est déperditif si c'est
bleu c'est pas déperditif en réalité il
y a énormément de contraintes qui
rentrent en ligne de comp en tout cas si
c'est rouge c'est pas bon signe on peut
déjà commencer à s'inquiéter voilà c'est
moins bon signe d'être rouge que bleu
mais malgré tout être bleu ne veut pas
forcément dire que c'est bon signe il y
a plusieurs contraintes qui on va
prendre en compte déjà la première chose
c'est est-ce que le bâtiment é chauffé
le soir de la réalisation de la
termographie aérienne puisque
malheureusement on est sur un territoire
où on a 150000 habitants à peu près les
150000 habitants étaaient pas forcément
tous présents le jour de la réalisation
du survol ça a été fait uniquement sur
les habitations ou sur été fait sur
l'ensemble du territoireation l'intérêt
de la termographie aérienne c'est
justement d'impacter toute une
population de tout le territoire voilà
donc du coup il y a ce premier aspect
donc déjà ensuite les autres aspects
c'est par exemple en fonction de la
nature des toitures les toitures ne
rayonnent pas de la même manière et donc
du coup l'image qu'on va avoir d'une
toiture ne va pas être la même entre une
toiture en qui est une toiture qui
rayonne très faiblement et donc du coup
qui va plutôt apparaître dans des
teintes bleuté et des toitures en tuile
qui vont si le bâtiment est chauffé par
en dessous vont apparaître en fonction
de l'isolation du bâtiment plutôt jaune
orange ou rouge en fonction du de la
nature de la toiture de la nature de
l'isolation en dessous alors justement
on va voir si le les les les cquantinois
savent ou non si leur habitat est
correctement isolé et pour ça nous avons
posé la question du
jour j'habite Man est à et l'isolation
est bien faite le double vitrage par
exemple très important bah pour
conserver la chaleur contre l'humidité
et surtout si on a des enfants donc pour
l'hygiène de vie quoi principalement et
puis essayer de pas trop dépenser
d'argent aussi pour dans le chauffage
bah c'est un aspect important et en plus
je suis sur un chauffage électrique
pourri donc ça joue beaucoup pour faire
des économies d'argent pour
l'environnement c'est quand même assez
importantprès c'est un budget mais après
je pense que finan sement on s retrouve
quoi ce qu'on peut constater c'est que
en tant que locataire les propriétaires
s'en fichent parce que c'est trop de
frais on est en train de le faire en
partie parce qu'on a des gros problèmes
de toiture donc ils sont en train de
rénover une partie de notre toiture les
gens ils font attention véritablement
ils sont venus vous voir depuis que les
résultats ont été collectés pour se
renseigner oui oui bien sûr on a depuis
que la thermographie a été réalisée
qu'elle a été rendue publique donc le 6
octobre elle a été rendue publique au
niveau de la communauté d'agglomération
on a énormément de particuliers de C qui
viennent nous solliciter pour avoir la
vision de leur toiture de leur maison et
ensuite ça nous permet ensuite de
pouvoir apporter un conseil en fonction
de ce que l'on voit donc c'est un la
thermographie é un vrai outil de
sensibilisation pour nous c'est de
trouver une solution derrière voilà et
ensuite de pouvoir les toucher sur du
Conseil concret par rapport à leur
maison comment ça se passe au niveau des
bailleurs sociaux et au niveau des
entreprises est-ce que même viennent
vous voir vous consulter alors ils ne
viennent pas directement au sein de nos
locaux à l'Agence Locale de l'énergie
mais par contre avec la communauté
d'agglomération de c-qutins en Yveline
on est dans un processus de Plan climat
énergie territoriale dans le cadre de ce
processus de Plan climat énergie
territoriale on a mis en place enfin la
communauté d'agglomération a mis en
place deux clubs climat des clubs climat
qui sont là pour réunir les entreprises
d'un côté et de l'autre côté les
bailleurs sociaux et de pouvoir du coup
réfléchir à des solutions concernant les
réductions des consommations
énergétiques la termographie est un
outil que l'on va utiliser auprès des
entreprises et auprès des bailleurs
sociaux dans ce cadre là d'accord donc
il y avait bien un forum pour informer
les cinquantinois le 6 octobre dernier
vous venez de le mentionner et donc nous
allons voir justement dans dans ce
reportage le le ce ce fameux forum
justement sur le le rendu des mesures
thmographiques donc là on a pas du tout
le même type de de comportement on a un
comportement très émissif là c'est une
voiture qui aimit beaucoup alors que là
on a une cinture qui réfléchit beaucoup
on va pouvoir grâce à cet outil là voir
plusieurs niveaux de couleur qui vont
aller du bleu très clair au rouge très
foncé et en fait donc le bleu va plutôt
correspondre à des à des dé perditions
FAI et le rouge a des déperditions
importantes malgré tout il y a un
certain niveau d'interprétation qui va
être difficile à effectuer par rapport à
certains niveau à certain nature de
toiture tel que les toitures en zinc
c'est une première dans l'agglomération
de canttin en Yveline les habitants
peuvent désormais connaître la
déperdition d'énergie de leur toiture
initiative prise dans le de sa politique
de développement durable les mesures ont
été réalisées en hiver quand les
habitations sont chauffées et partent en
clair pour réaliser ces mesures nous
disposons d'un scanner infrarouge un
capteur qui nous permet de mesurer le
rayonnement infrarouge de des toitures
qui est intégré dans un avion un avion
bimoteur qui nous permet de voler la
nuit à 500 m d'altitude adessus des
zones urbaines j'ai appris que les
travaux qu'on avait fait récemment avait
servi à isoler la maison et qu'on avait
un bon résultat en terme de déperdition
de chaleur donc ça ça me conforte un
petit peu dans dans ce qu'on a réalisé
auparavant les cinquantinois peuvent
donc désormais s'informer sur
l'isolation thermique de leur habitat
des permanences sont organisées les 18
et 19 octobre à l'Agence Locale de
l'énergie libre à eux ensuite de se
rapprocher d'un conseiller afin de
trouver des solutions pour réduire leurs
dépenses
énergétiques alors Girbau je me retourne
vers vous lorsque l'on est dans dans un
bâtiment tout en vert comme celui-ci
qu'on a froid toute la journée à tous
les étages comment faire pour y remédier
est-ce qu'il y a vraiment une sol voilà
mais on a un grand bâtiment en vert
voilà rempli de baie vitré comment ça se
passe pour isoler sans modifier la
structure est-ce qu'il y a une
possibilité alors il y a des solutions
qui existent he bien entendu après en
réalité au départ ce qu'il est important
de savoir c'est de d'avoir la cause
de des perditions ce genre de choses
donc la mesure thermographique est un
outil qui nous permet de voir ces
éléments là après on peut compléter cela
par un diagnostic plus complet du
bâtiment un diagnostic énergétique qui
va nous dire si ça provient plutôt de la
toiture si ça provient plutôt des baaies
vitrées en effet si on est sur un
bâtiment qui est vitré les déperdition
thermique par des vitres sont plus
importantes que par des murs donc voilà
bien entendu lorsqu'on a tout vitré
c'est compliqué de pou la solution voilà
pour les gens qui habitent dans le même
immeuble qui travaillent dans le même
immeuble que les salariés de téléfil
c'est de muré
voilà forcément après il existe des
solutions techniques qui sont
développées aujourd'hui tels que des
murs mteaux ou des ou des double pot en
fait où on peut mettreinstant on est
plutôt à mettre des allez-y voilà donc
on va revenir donc au particuliier aux
mesures thmographiques qui sont
disponibles jusqu'à quand elles sont
disponibles jusqu'à ce que les
particuliers tous les particuliers de
C50 ans viennent la
consulter jour nécessaire ceci dit il y
a d'autres mesures qui sont prévu pour
l'instant il n'y a pas d'autres mesures
qui sont prévues en tout cas ce n'est
pas une c'est pas une mise à jour qui se
fera de manière annuelle euh pour
l'instant on vient de réaliser une
mesure en début d'année donc on va
utiliser cette mesure là ce qu'on peut
savoir c'est que minimum dans pour 5 ans
cette mesure elle sera existante voilà
les particuliers même s'ils viennent
nous voir dans un an cette mesure sera
fiable à partir du moment où ils
n'auront pas réalisé de travaux
d'isolation de leur toiture entre le 8
mars 2012 et la et la période où ils
viendront nous voir si bien entendu ils
ont fait des travaux entre-temps on aura
une différence puisque l'isolation a é
effectué merci donc à tous les deux
d'être nous parler de de ces mesures
thermographiques voilà vous pouvez
consulter hein si vous habitez sur
Saint-Quentin en Yveline Valérie on
poursuit la chronique de l'environnement
l'agenda maintenant oui ce soir
wilfreded à 20h30 à la Maison de
l'Environnement la projection d'un film
tempête sous un crâne est proposé suivi
d'un débat sur le thème du collège et de
l'école et puis les 25 et 24 et 25
novembre prochain artisan du monde
organise une vente de produits bio et
issu du commerce équitable en vue des FA
fête de fin d'année à Saint-Quentin les
sources à Montini le Bretonneux voilà
les dates à retenir en ce qui concerne
l'environnement merci Valérie on vous
retrouve la semaine prochaine mêmes
horaires si vous nous suivez en direct
c'est aux alentours de 18h20 et puis
n'oubliez pas les rediffusions notre
site internet aussi vous pouvez revoir
tous nos reportages toutes nos
interviews et laisser vos commentaires
ainsi que sur les réseaux sociaux dans
un instant nous reviendrons sur la
journée nationale de la trisomi 21 avec
un nouvel invité pour le moment retour
sur la contestation d'une partie des
élus du département contre le nouveau
mode de calcul du fond de solidarité de
la région île-de-fance un fond destiné à
aider les communes les plus
pauvres le maire de guillancour est
inquiet dans le cadre de la loi de
finances 2012 mise en place par l'ancien
gouvernement le fond de solidarité de la
région Île-de-France a été modifié
certaines communes exonérées de
prélèvement sur la base de critères
sociaux ne le sont désormais plus c'est
le cas de guillancour poissie Nanterre
ou encore Saint-Ouin en tout 8 maire
d'Île-de-France se sont associés dans
une lettre commune au gouvernement
objectif proposer des amendements à la
loi de finance 2013 en préparation nous
ne sommes pas contre la solidarité mais
nous sommes pour le fait qu'elle soit
juste ce qu'il n'est pas bon c'est de
ponctionn à hauteur de 1008 une commune
comme Guill en courour c'est brutal et
c'est inéquitable c'est trois fois le
budget consacré aux actions sociales
pour les habitants de la ville on ne
peut pas donc prendre sur le budget de
la ville pour donner ailleurs et ne pas
laisser ce qui permet à la commune de
guillancour d'agir vis de ses
administrés auparavant les critères
sociaux des villes étaient pris en
compte dans le calcul des prélèvements
avec 50 % de logement sociaux et un
revenu moyen par habitant relativement
faible Guill en cour en était exonéré le
collectif propose de rétablir ce
dispositif nous demandons de l'équité
par exemple que des communes qui ont des
ressources et une population aisée ne
soi pas plafonné et protégé comme elles
le sont quand des communes comme les
nôtres qui en cours qui ont des charges
vis-à-vis de populations elles ne sont
pas plafonnées et protégées ça ça serait
la première des des mesures et puis la
deuxième c'est d'urgence de rétablir des
critères sociaux prendre en compte les
populations concernées avant de de
définir le montant des contributions le
troisème amendement proposé par les h
maires est une augmentation progressive
des prélèvements en fonction du budget
de fonctionnement de la ville
aujourd'hui ces prélèvements sont
plafonnés à 10 % le projet de loi de
finances 2013 est en cours d'examen au
Parlement